une première concertation qui commence
tout d'abord par un état des lieux avec
plus de 500 millions d'euros de chiffre
d'affaires annuel la zone maurepas
coignières est le deuxième pôle majeur
de l'agglomération sur les 160 mille
mètres carrés de zone commerciale on
dénombre 250 magasins qui génère plus de
2000 emplois un territoire qui présente
donc de nombreuses forces
même si les commerçants présents ont
pointé du doigt quelques faiblesses je
m'aperçois que cette zone a des petits
problèmes de fréquentation on a une zone
qui est un petit peu désertique en
semaine et j'étais très très inquiet de
la non réactivité je suis venu ici pour
m'informer et j'en ressors un peu plus
satisfait car je m'aperçois que d'autres
gens que moir ont les mêmes soucis
les interrogations et travaille au
développement de cette zone hyper
important quand on doit s'adresser à
quelqu'un on n'a souvent pas le bon
interlocuteur
ça passe dans non à laudun non à l'autre
et on arrive souvent pas à voir la
personne dont on a besoin et donc là ça
permet ce que tout le monde se connaît
on sait à peu près qui va s'occuper de
quoi mieux connaître les attentes des
commerçants des propriétaires et des
gestionnaires de sites afin de
développer au mieux cette zone voici
l'objectif de saint quentin en yvelines
pour repenser la stratégie commerciale
du territoire il y aura d'autres
évidemment réunion mais on reste
toujours maintenant en contact parce que
l'objectif c'est aussi d'avoir leurs
coordonnées d'avoir aussi d'évolution de
chiffre d'affaires pour voir un peu
comment il se situe prochaines zones
concernées par ces concertations plaisir
et les clayes-sous-bois en octobre
prochain